here you are your school is being sued
all over the national newspapers what's
going on we're being sued for a prayer
room I'm not saying that no school
should have a prayer room I'm saying it
can't work for us we would have to
abandon everything that we are like that
is to divide according to race and
religion and I will never divide the
children according to race and religion
I don't believe in that there were the
death threats there was the bomb threat
the police had to come and search the
school for bombs one morning I don't
understand it we've all lost our minds I
mean we've lost our minds
Katherine burbling welcome back to the
show for the nth time I don't know how
many times you've been on here before I
have to say you are literally the least
Troublemaker of all our guests oh I
think that's not saying much that is not
well I don't know about that I think we
have some pretty controversal people on
regularly but you are the person that I
least expect to be causing trouble out
there and whatever and yet here you are
your school is being sued all over the
national newspapers what's going on well
um we're being sued uh for a prayer room
uh one of the children uh would like one
and we don't have one um although we've
never had one we opened in
2014 um and we've been going ever since
and of course we're known for being very
strict U Michaela is in Wembley in
London in the inner city and we have a
typical inner city intake um and I'm
considered to be uh Britain's strictest
head mistress you admit it you like that
label don't you well you know if you
type to Google who is the strictest
teacher in the world my name comes up so
um we have very strict rules and um
because of those rules and the building
uh it's just not really possible to have
prayer rooms I should say rooms because
we've got 350 Muslims obviously one
prayer room wouldn't be enough so we'd
have to have several rooms and because
of our Logistics and so on it's just not
possible so we've always said from the
beginning that we don't have prayer
rooms because it isn't possible and you
know the families understand that and
they sign up anyway and they send us
their children and and why is it sorry
just to finish this that seems like a
fairly normal thing why is this become
such a big deal in the public
conversation now why are people talking
about it because it seems like a fairly
routine standard thing you sort it out
you go to court blah blah blah you know
whatever but it's become a big talking
point in the in the kind of broader
culture why do you think that is well
because we're going to court people feel
that it's wrong um for a child to take
the school to court for this reason um I
I suppose people feel that um schools
ought to be allowed to be secular places
um and we are very much a secular school
um we are also a very Multicultural
School uh multifaith multi-race multi
everything and um we we are asking all
the various different groups in the
school to make sacrifices for the
betterment of the whole so isn't this
what this is really about K and this is
kind of why I was asking you the
question because you're someone who
because of your own background and
because of the background of the kids
that you've got under your uh leadership
essentially at your school you
understand that in order for different
races and different groups to work
together they all have to subscribe to a
bigger thing that's above everybody and
that's one and you are against the idea
of dividing people by skin color
religion Etc that's right and you know
that the society we live in doesn't seem
to want that to be the case and isn't
that really why we are sitting here
talking about this well possibly I mean
there is the court case
so you know and that obviously uh people
you know there's some people who would
very much want us to win it and some
people who want us to lose it um and
um the when I say the different groups
so yes you're right that in many schools
you'll find that there is the LGBT group
or there's the black Caribbean group or
there's the Hindu group and so on and um
we don't do that we consider all our
children to be British and I think often
ethnic minorities are denied the
opportunity to call themselves British
uh by both the right and the left
politically uh the left because they
insist that actually ethnic minorities
are from somewhere else you know um when
actually we're all British and we should
all be able to call ourselves British so
we sing God Save The King and I Ved thee
my country and you know we we stand for
the head mistress and we're very
traditional in our approach and um so it
isn't just that we don't have prayer
rooms because people then say to me well
you don't like Islam No that's not the
case we're trying to make everything
work for everyone so we have McBeth as
um one of our gcsc texts uh it has
witches in it the Jehovah Witnesses
don't like that it's against their
religion but they put up with it because
well that's what we've got uh some of
the Hindus have said oh you know we
don't like the fact that at lunch the uh
eggs touch the plates um we'd like our
own plates but that would mean
separating the Hindus so I'm not doing
that and they put up with it uh all of
the different groups have to make
sacrifices in order for us all to get on
and one way in which this uh showed
itself right at the beginning when we
opened up in 2014 we open as a normal
school with meat in the in the canteen
and we do a family lunch where all the
children they sit in groups of six they
always have a set seat one serves the
food the other pours the water one of
them cleans up afterwards it's a lovely
I always call it the Beating Heart of
the school it's wonderful and um we do
this uh with with the understanding of
we're socializing the children it's one
of the things we do at Michaela and so
people sort of say well it's their free
time they can do what they want to lunch
well we don't believe in that we believe
that all of the time that they're in
school were doing something with them
actually and so this family
lunch uh there are different children on
the tables eating the food some are
Muslims some are Hindus some are black
some are white and so on
um when we first started we asked the
children well what do you eat you know
and some said I eat meat but no pork
because I'm a Muslim I me I eat meat but
no beef because I'm a Hindu and so on
when we placed them out accordingly in
the dining hall I looked at the space
and said we've just divided the children
according to race and religion we can't
do that we're going to have to go
vegetarian and that way everyone can sit
next to each other and we can make
friendships across the RCI racial and
and religious divides and so we've
always been vegetarian for that reason
so we're all sacrificing because the
vast majority of children would like to
eat meat but everyone doesn't eat meat
in order to make sure that we are um in
order to make sure that we are all
friends with each other and that's one
of the things the beauty of Michaela um
is that
uh you know we don't have issues between
groups you know you might visit some
other inner city schools you will find
fights happening between the racial
groups between the religious groups
you'll find um big issues that happen
outside of school between these
groupings whereas at Michaela they are
friends across those divides and that is
because we are socializing them in that
way all the time and what is quite sad
is that and this is for both the right
and the left politically the left feel
that actually we should just be always
celebrating diversity and that there's
nothing to unify us at all and while
obviously I'm all for um some diversity
you know we eat different foods we might
go to churches and mosques and temples
and so on and that's fine but we also
need to find things that unite us and
the cohesion of a community in a school
for me is really important now obviously
if you're in a school where things are a
lot more relaxed and um you know
children do what they like at
lunchtime uh and they roam around the
corridors and they can go in out of
classrooms then clearly you might want
to have a prayer room and that's fine
you know I'm not saying that no school
should have a prayer room I'm saying it
can't work for us given the nature of
our family lunch given the nature of our
corridors we walk in silence in the
corridors uh the children are not
allowed to roam freely they all go
outside together so um and and then when
they're outside we are making sure that
everyone is mixing if there's a child
being left out we're bringing him back
into the fold um which is why you know
bullying is at an absolute minimum and
if we were to find something we would
stamp it out immediately um and and
that's why our children are so happy and
why it's such a lovely place to be um
and that that for me you know is is the
is the beautiful thing about Michaela I
mean Michaela sure last two years we've
had the highest progress eight meaning
that we've been the top school in terms
of in the whole country of the 4,000 odd
secondary schools there are in the whole
country we from year seven right through
year 11 when they take the TCS the last
two years they have made the most
progress at our school in comparison to
anywhere else and so people say oh the
results the results and I've always said
the thing I'm most happy about most
proud of is not the results it's who our
children are and who they are amongst
each other and um so the left want to
just celebrate this whole diversity
thing and let's separate everybody into
groups and how do you identify and which
group do you belong to which I think is
the wrong way to go and then you've got
the right I just read this article
actually where um uh someone
arguing from the right against us saying
that um we're having to do do
peacekeeping amongst all these groups
who hate each other that just isn't true
you know as adult adult s with children
whether you're parents or teachers it's
our role to help to socialize them to be
good citizens and good people that's
what we should be doing and that's what
we are doing at Michaela we're not
keeping the peace between groups that
hate each other and um you're teaching
kids not to hate each other and to be
friends with each other that's what
you're doing and we're teaching so this
guy who was writing was saying you know
we don't want multiculturalism you know
forget multiculturalism now
multiculturalism is division which often
it is you know so I understand why
people on the right will say that of
some Multicultural situations I get that
but if we can make it so that we
understand each other and we all
understand this idea of sacrificing for
the whole um and that everyone
sacrifices whatever it may be um why is
this a bad thing what I don't understand
on the right is that they just go on
multiculturalism failed it's failed it's
failed what are you going to do get all
of us out of the country I mean is that
what you're doing I mean I I don't
understand what your solution is uh my
solution is that with children we teach
them how to be kind to each other um
because even when you have a group of
white children they'll pick on the
smaller one they'll pick on the one with
the ginger hair the pick on the one like
that's always the case the fact is
children need to be taught how to get on
with each other and how to like each
other and um and obviously you do that
in the confines of what you you know as
the
we are very strict so our very strict
rules uh prevent wandering around
classrooms and corridors and so on our
ethos is such um that prayer rooms
simply wouldn't work the building is
also extremely restrictive you can't um
when we do our family lunch I can't
dismiss all of the Muslim children
upstairs to pray and all of the
non-muslim children outside like that is
to divide according to race and religion
and I will never divide the children
according to race and religion um I
don't believe in that um
so that's why we're fighting this um now
and the other thing that this guy said
in this article that so annoyed me was
that he was saying well it's obviously
failed Michaela multiculturalism
obviously Fails Like no it hasn't failed
we we've we've been going for 10 years
um yes there is one family that's doing
this but on the other night we had a
year 11 parents evening packed 100%
attendants all of them there massive
Hall filled with everyone um it was the
day that I was on the cover of the
evening standard the parents actually
had some of them had copies of it and
they were in their bags and so on not
one of them said anything about the
issues that have going on in the Press
about the school about the court case
about any of it not one of them we
talked about GCS we talked about working
hard we talked about how we support our
kids at home um my my teachers were
telling me how parents were hugging them
and thanking them for all of their hard
work and this is 50% Muslim population
in the in the room you know like so this
idea that it's impossible for Muslims to
uh get on with other people who are not
Muslim it's just it's a nonsense you
know the fact is that our children and
our families have got on for many years
and everything's gone well so to just
take this one situation and say well
there you go it's failed it hasn't
failed in fact we succeed every single
day not just in terms of the results but
in terms of the people who who they are
and and so I criticize the right for
saying that and then I criticize the
left who then say to me well unless you
provide all these prayer rooms and
abolish your ethos and we'd have to move
the bags and the coats out of the rooms
we'd have to move all the furniture and
the kids would have to be doing it daily
we would have total chaos in my view in
some people's view it would be fine it'd
be more of a normal school but it
wouldn't be our strict school we
wouldn't have 800 visitors coming to the
school anymore every year because we do
we have 800 visitors coming to look to
say wow this is such an amazing place
place we would have to abandon
everything that we are in order to
provide these prayer rooms now I I think
it's wrong to expect us to do that I
think that obviously look we're a very
different school at the beginning
when when families come to find out
about us I tell them I don't just tell
them about the prayer lack of prayer
room I tell them that we have silent
corridors I tell them that um the kids
have family lunch I tell them they all
go outside and they play in this way and
so on I explain all the differences that
make us different from other schools
because as I always say to them look
when you go to a shop and you buy a kit
kat you want to get home and find a Kit
Kat in your bag you don't want to find a
mbar so I'm going to tell you everything
that you might not like about the school
and then it's up to you right um and if
you decide to come on board well you
need to come on board with everything
that we are you know now and to me
Catherine that seems absolutely fair
enough and for everybody listening they
can have a drink because I'm going to
say the words I used to be a teacher I
get it I get it I get everything I
really support what you do I always
thought that that is the most effective
way to run a school the more structure
that you have particularly for kids who
lack structure outside of the
educational establishment they crave it
and they need it and it sounds and it
looks like the school is are roaring
success at what point did you notice
that you actually had a problem here
okay that's yeah very good question so
never had a prayer room uh the kids have
always been fine with that it's never
been an issue um and then last year
during
Ramadan uh in the yard a few kids
decided to pray now we've always said
that prayer would be allowed in the yard
for the kids uh these are the lower
school kids always said prayer would be
allowed but nobody chosen to pray in the
yard and so it was always well it just
wasn't an issue before I have to say it
wasn't an issue when they first started
praying either it's fine it was allowed
we didn't you know it was fine um but
then there was a an incident where um
some children were badly behaved round
the prayer and uh uh petition started up
online now the children apparently were
not involved in this I'm assuming people
from outside were people could see
through the gates you know what's going
on outside and of course if the children
are praying in the yard then well why
don't they have a prayer room so there
was this petition that started up
demanding a prayer room thousands of
people signed it now none of this got
into the main press at the time and uh
we were very grateful you know uh we we
had a media ban on this actually for all
this time since that those events until
now when you say we the the judge banned
this from being disced just so just to
be clear people don't think the
strictest head mistress in the world has
banned the media no no no we'd gone to
court and managed to get a media ban uh
which was then lifted last week in court
which is why suddenly we've been thrown
into the Press I was desperate for it to
remain cuz some people who criticize me
say oh well she obviously just wants to
be in the news no no no we were arguing
to keep that ban now we were very lucky
when this happened because we didn't end
up in the media and it only stayed
online but even when I say online on
social media a few blogs were written uh
there were some videos made on Tik Tok
and that kind of thing now um because of
this petition and because of the the
furor that happened online we then
started getting death threats and all
kinds of abuse one of my teachers black
teacher uh got horribly racially abused
you know being called the n-word the CW
compared to a monkey all kinds of
horrible horrible things and I'm talking
15 to 20 you know Commons you know it's
not just um one one thing uh there were
the death threats there was the bomb
threat um the police had to come and
search the school for bombs one morning
uh both uh that teacher of mine and me
we had to take um uh you know lifts into
school and so on because we were
frightened to travel um one of my
teachers had her uh an attempted
break-in at her flat uh one of my
teachers had a brick thrown through her
window uh we had bottles thrown into the
yard there was loads of intimidation and
aggression that was all coming from the
outside we had to hire security um the
police were outside often um and it was
a terrifying time uh we also had to
close the school early just before the
holidays because we were meant to go out
on some school trips and they just
couldn't happen um it was it was awful
and um so when was this Catherine just
so this was about March last year March
last year and um during Ramadan uh now
what was also interesting was what
happened at school which was that
uh so during Ramadan some of the
children some of the Muslim children
fast some of them don't um obviously we
have Muslim children who who cover their
heads some of them don't um
and obviously we had some children who
prayed and some of them did not but what
happened was that the culture changed
over the days this was happening and um
the children who were praying some of
them would then go to the break hole
food table and intimidate the other ones
uh who were not fasting because they
chosen not to fast for whatever reason
they're Muslim but they don't want to
fast um and they were made to feel I
suppose as if they were you know doing
something wrong by not fasting and uh so
they were intimidated into fasting and
they weren't able to take the food a
girl one girl she was suddenly started
wearing a hijab even though she didn't
wear one before one girl dropped out of
the choir because music is considered
Haram um uh all of these things more
children started praying more children
started praying and so on and the
intimidation so there was the horrible
intimidation and aggression that was
happening outside but then there was the
intimidation that was happening between
the children
now the thing is it's my duty as head
mistress to protect all the children not
just one particular group so this
includes the Muslim children who are
being intimidated but it also includes
everyone you know so that everyone can
feel happy and comfortable in our
environment so the governors took the
decision to uh ban prayer because
obviously of what had happened and we
were in danger I mean our lives were
literally in danger um so prayer was
banned and you know fascinating because
as soon as that happened and prayer
stopped everything just went back to
normal the children were happy again
everything was fine and calm and lovely
and everyone was mixing across the races
um it was
just it that incident that time totally
transformed the school into something
that wasn't very nice and um so yeah
we're fighting for you know the right to
be able to run the school as we see fit
really you remember the Canadian trucker
protest in 2022 where thousands of
Canadians came out to protest covid
restrictions and vaccine mandates now
these protests lasted for weeks and the
people out on the streets needed money
as any Grassroots protest would so
people set up online crowdfunding
campaigns which raised millions of
dollars it was incredible but those
campaigns were closed down and the money
didn't get to the protesters because the
Canadian authorities started to
criticize the crowdfunding platforms
ramping up pressure on them to close the
campaigns the biggest crowdfunding
platform the one we've all heard of
completely capitulated to the demands
now this is where our partners gifs and
go come in they stepped in when the
other platforms backed off and raised
millions of dollars for the truckers
when they were criticized and dragged
through the Canadian courts GI and go
came out and said they respect diverse
views and believe hope and freedom are
values worth fighting for this is why
we're proud to partner with them so if
you need to crowd fund for whatever
means the most to you then don't go to
the big Tech platforms go to give Center
go starting a campaign on give send go
is easy and intuitive go to gend go.com
today that's gend go.com to start
raising money for whatever matters to
you when did you know that there was a
court case
looming um well I suppose it was soon
after the the that in the time in March
um that we knew that that was happening
now of course all of that it takes ages
before you actually get to call
um and then there was this media ban so
nobody was writing about us I think a
couple of Articles appeared in the last
year uh in the papers but they just
talked generally about a school
somewhere in Britain you know so um it
wasn't us and then on Tuesday last week
we had the case in the courts and I was
there and our Barrister was arguing to
keep the ban uh because of the death
threats and so on
but I mean the judge has a hard job he's
trying to weigh up uh our interests
against the interests of the public and
he was saying well this is of the
interest it's in the interest of the
public to read about this various
members of the press stood up and made
their case for why they thought it
should be made public our Barrister made
the case for why it would be dangerous
for us the judge in the end decided that
the family should not be named and that
um the teachers should not be Nam named
but that I and the schools should be
named now I mean ultimately if you name
the school you name me um so I get it um
and so he threw us into the Limelight
and I have been defending our decision
uh to uh ban prayer because um obviously
if we don't well you can imagine we lose
the narrative and nobody really
understands why we've done what we've
done so uh we've been out I've been out
just explaining that on some of the news
outlets and
and that must be really quite stressful
because when you when you look at the
situation you're talking about banning
prayer that would significantly RI a
certain percentage of M the Muslim
Community do do you have you ever felt
worried about your own particular safety
now that it's now that you've been
thrust into the Limelight yeah so it was
very bad last year this year we've had
one I think to the to to the school
threat um although um my PA was saying
oh Katherine I just haven't been sending
you stuff so I don't know what what
there is um and then also online there
are things that get said uh and so yes
when I'm on the tube and so on I'm
looking around me I am worried um I I I
I do have to be careful um because it
only takes one crazy person you know and
and that's it so it's um yeah that is
that is a worry um I also understand
that it is I I certainly understand now
since um you know when the judge was
saying I was so angry with him when he
lifted the ban and I was thinking how
can it be that you know our lives are at
stake here and that you're lifting this
ban but having seen the amount of public
interest that there's been since I sort
of think well maybe he was right you
know um he he's making a a judgment
without the emotion tied up in it which
I'm obviously feeling and the fear that
I feel so you can hear my voice is gone
um so it has been a very stressful time
um uh but I mean it has been the case
and you guys have known me you know
since a long time ago um uh I've always
had to fight for the school people have
been fighting us ever since we well from
before we established it took us three
and a half years to establish because
because so many detractors were stopping
us from opening the school um uh we've
been people have protested outside
before uh trying to stop us um from well
having the kids when we first started
claiming that the kids were in danger uh
in the building and all sorts of
nonsense uh with placards insulting me
and shouting abuse at me and so on um we
we when we before we opened we would
have parent evenings where uh we'd be
telling uh people about this new school
and people would um would would they
would bust people in from out of London
I mean this is the things that were so
crazy so we tried to open the school
originally in in Brixton and we had an
event at a pub and uh I was handing out
all these flyers to all these black moms
at the at the market and down you know
the various mosques and churches and so
on and um they all came and there were
all these white people who were standing
outside with placards uh calling me a
tory teacher and shouting abuse at me we
had to hire bouncers for the possible
violence that might ensue from this
whole thing and so these are the the
left who supposedly care about ethnic
minorities having a great education here
we are trying to provide an excellent
education and they are campaigning
against now I say the left this is the
extreme left obviously you know there's
lots of very sensible people on the left
um and uh you
know there was one event that we had
where one woman because I had spoken at
the Conservative Party Conference in
2010 which is what threw me in the
Limelight in the first place and I'm not
a conservative I'm not a member of the
conservative party I do call myself a
small C conservative but I would argue
that many of The Big C conservatives are
not small C conservatives y um but um
when I spoke at that Conservative Party
Conference this made people very angry
and I would argue that that has to do
with being uh an ethnic minority woman
that you're not allowed to have um uh
views that are conservative you have to
vote on the left you have to think on
the left you know and if you don't
people get very very angry about it and
I remember one woman that one of our
events she stood up often they would
stand up and shout when we were trying
to talk to the parents in order to drown
us out so the parents wouldn't be able
to hear what we were saying she stood up
and said you betrayed us when you went
to speak at the Conservative Party
Conference and I thought but I don't
even know who you
are what do you mean I betrayed you but
I think what she meant was you as Who
You Are you're an ethnic minority woman
you are meant to be with us on this
fighting the evil conservatives and then
you went to their conference and you D
speak there you know so um uh and I did
dare speak there because I think for
myself you know I don't agree with the
conservatives on everything obviously
sometimes I don't know kir sta says
something I agree with I absolutely hate
what rishy sunak is saying about the
British Advanced standard and getting
rid of a levels and so on I I I mean I'm
completely against that um and I've
written about it I mean the fact
is if you if you think for yourself then
you might agree with something the labor
party says you might agree with
something the conservative party says
you know I am a small C conservative
what does that mean and these are well
these are values that we give um the
kids at the school which I think really
make us what we are well and it's one of
the reasons I think all of these things
that you're saying Katherine is since we
met you and and found more out about
Michaela I've personally found you
inspiring and you're someone I really
admire because you're someone who's
consistently willing to stick up for the
things that she knows are right even
when it's difficult as it is in this
case and you attract a lot of negative
publicity and all sorts of um you know
very unfortunate threats and so on which
you know I hope obviously we all do
don't materialize in any way and I
obviously that shouldn't be happening in
the first place but I think as you say
the reason the story has attracted as
much of public commentary is it sort of
feels a little bit like a test case for
all the things that you alluded to
earlier for both left and right because
the right has now gone into a a kind of
reactionary position on to some extent
where it's like multiculturalism has
failed which it has we should
acknowledge this right the idea that we
should divide people according to the
very issues that you just talked about
you know the white person standing up
and going you betrayed us that's that's
not that's not a multi-racial society
like ours cannot be made to work age and
so you can obviously we all understand
the frustrations people feel
however the answer to that has to be to
Advocate on a national level what you've
instituted at Micha which is look I
don't care if you're Muslim I don't care
if you're Hindu I don't care if you're
black brown white whatever we're all
here Under One Roof and we're all going
to pull in the same direction and work
together because we're all Michaela
students or because we're all British or
because we're all American or whatever
that label is and everyone has to
sacrifice and it can't just be me me me
my group my group over everyone else
right right that's it in a nutshell
that's it in a nutshell and so that's
kind of where I think the right is misre
it's not the right it's not the right
it's some people on the right some
people true but the thing is like one of
the things look I do think for myself so
I come on a show where I know there are
going to be lots of right-wing people
talking and I say you know what there is
such a thing as racism because I think
there is and uh when I'm saying look I
think ethnic minorities like me there's
a reason why so braan and pretty Patel
and KY Bok get the hatred that they get
it's it's intense and it's so intense
because they're women of color who say
the things that they say and they're not
allowed to say them they're not allowed
to be on the right and I'm not saying
that I agree with everything they say
you know I am not part of the
conservative party um but the fact is
that we should be able to think for
ourselves and ethnic minorities are not
allowed to and there's a real problem
with that well actually no one is
allowed to anymore this was where I was
going because I think so with the right
there is that overreaction where yes
multiculturalism hasn't worked but the
solution is to create a multiethnic
society that works because we are a
multiethnic society you're not going to
get away from that well that's it what
are they going to do put me on a boat
and send me to Jamaica I mean this is
ridiculous but the left uh the left also
has an issue with what you doing for the
precise reasons that they oppose the
very thing that you cherish which is
everybody coming together and working
together they want to and being British
they want to split everybody apart and
say you're this group you're that group
we can look at your skin color and say
these are the opinions you should have
and this is your level of Oppression and
blah blah blah that's why it seems to me
this case has got the attention that
it's got because you're standing up for
a very important principle against
frankly what some people might interpret
as the expression of an intolerant
minority view of which there are
different versions from all sides yeah
although I wouldn't say that it's so
minority these days I mean what I mean
is people don't sort of realize it you
know just everyone sort of thinks in
that divisive way you know so I would
say in 1995 we had far better race
relations than we do now um you know
because everybody now just sees color
because that's all anybody ever talks
about so I have people who say to me
would you like to join our board because
we really need a diverse board do you
slap them because you should well and I
think to myself do you know all that
I've achieved do you know anything about
me like I don't understand how you look
at me and all you see is brown skin
that's all you see you know I don't
understand that and um and the thing is
because the um well I say because
for some people I see some of the
comments on there about you know when I
when when I'm trying to defend us you
know and uh some of the comments against
Muslims or Muslim children and I just
think this is all wrong you know so I'm
not just saying racism comes from just
from the left it also comes from the
right and some of the comments that I
see I just think no no no no no look I'm
the one being taken to court right I who
you can't talk like this you know now
like because as I say we had our year 11
parents evening and we had a group a a
mixed group of people in there Muslims
and Hindus black and white all types and
everybody was there together and when I
say about the thing about being British
I think that's important it's the one
thing that we have in common yes now the
right can keep Camp you know the more
the extreme right can keep campaigning
about well multiculturalism fails we
need to get rid of these people fine
that's not really a solution as far as
I'm concerned that's not going to work
exactly we children look the number one
thing everybody needs to understand is
the importance of schools this is all I
keep saying is the importance of schools
and nobody listens to me and nobody
cares about schools um people sort of
think rich people think it's all right
I'll just get my kid into a private
school and he'll be okay people tend to
panic when their child is in your six
and they're worried about where they're
going to get the child to for secondary
school and once he's in the secondary
school and he seems okay they leave it
people don't seem to realize that
schools are not just uh engines of
social Mobility
they're also engines of social cohesion
right and it's there that children
become who they're going to be as adults
and their families and their schools are
the are what play the most important
role in making them into who they're
going to be and
if we want to have a future for the
country we must look to our
schools nobody cares about the schools
so the the pundits you know like you
whoever you know we once had Jordan
Peterson come to our school and I said
to him why do you never talk about
schools because he never does now since
he came I noticed he does mention
schools a little bit more he's probably
terrified of you Catherine I would if
you said that to me but he he he said oh
I don't know so no and I said because
you don't care about them that's why
nobody cares about schools nobody talks
about it should be mandatory all of you
guys should be forced to be talking
about schools all the time okay because
it is the they are the future to our
country absolutely you know and so and
the only time people get interested
really in schools is when it's an issue
around gender that everybody's going oh
what's going on in schools or it's an
issue about critical race Theory being
taught oh what's going on in schools and
look I'm glad I'm glad to be honest I'm
almost grateful for those recent I I am
I'm almost grateful because because
people L paying attention people are
suddenly looking at schools I have been
shouting about this for 15 years
nobody's been listening and the reason
why critical race Theory and gender
studies and all this sort of stuff has
been has been happening in schools is
because children have been leading the
learning for 20 30 years now what do I
mean by that child-centered learning as
opposed to teacher-led learning we have
lost who where have the adults gone
right the adults need to be in a
position of authority in the front of
the classroom leading the learning for
many years now I say 20 or 30 it's
actually been longer than that really
since the 60s this has been happening um
child- centered learning has embedded
itself in our schools what that means is
children are in groups they are leading
what they're doing and the teacher is
the facilitator of learning moving
amongst the desks keeping the children
on task the teacher is no longer The
Authority leading the way I always say
the teacher should be driving the bus
and you're keeping the children on the
bus with you and you decide where you're
going you set the standards of the
discipline the leadership team at the
school runs with lead and leads what the
culture of the school what people often
don't understand about our
school so when the talking about the
situation about prayer they say well
it's 5 minutes what difference does it
make it's their free time they can do
what they like so
what look in our school there really is
no free time in a way you know yes
they're playing basketball and yes
they're chatting to each other but the
teachers are all there and they're all
making sure that we are being socialized
in a way that means that eventually when
we let the little birdies fly they are
good citizens and they are people that
we can be proud of you know um there's
um one of my deputies once gave me this
quote which is um says you can be
friends with your children when they are
children or when they are adults you
cannot be both right and it's the same
goes for parents parents who want to be
friends with their kids you can't be
friends with your kids you're meant to
be in charge of them you're meant to be
Role Models you're meant to lead the way
and the adults have left the room the
adults have left the room at home and
they've left the room in the schools and
I've been saying this for years and then
what's happened is because the children
are leading everything that's why
they've led us straight into this
madness right that is happening in too
many schools where children are being
divided and um and then it's become the
norm now it's become so much the norm
that you know if anyone tries to push
back against that then you know we we
can be vilified and that that is what
has happened to me we'll get back to the
episode in a minute but first we want to
tell you about our sponsor Vero in our
recent interview with Tim Urban he he
said we should be talking about
longevity and Longevity science
researchers like the biologist David
Sinclair have recently made some
fascinating discoveries on how to
mitigate or even slow down aging
altogether and that is why I'm using
Verso Verso is a company that translates
these incredible scientific
breakthroughs into products that hold
the potential to increase your longevity
and one of their products I take every
day is called cell beinging cell
beinging helps combat aging by
increasing something called NAD Plus in
your body NAD is arguably the most
important molecule in your body high NAD
levels improve your metabolism repair
damaged DNA and increase energy
production in your brain immune system
and muscles but as you grow old your
body's NAD levels go down and you can't
take NAD as a supplement because it's
too big for your cells to absorb that's
why Verso cell being contains nmn
Resveratrol and TMG these three
molecules work together to increase NAD
plus levels if you want to read more
about this check out the scientific
research Linked In the description of
the video plus Verso publishes third
party testing on every batch of its
products to guarantee that you're
getting exactly what you're paying for
so if you want to join us you can get
15% off by going to
v.s O that's
v.s o and use code trigger to save 15%
off your order now back to the interview
the one thing that I've noticed because
I've worked in many schools both
academically
outstanding tough schools and places
like newm and what I've noticed is that
the individual has now become more
important than the group or the
collective yeah and when that happens
what you get is chaos
was this
isct
one deed that this is unacceptable so
everybody else can
go do what they need to do but I need to
do this regardless of the chaos that it
causes the thing is is that in any group
whether it's multi-racial or not you're
going to have to make sacrifices you
could take a group of white kids yeah
they're all going to have to make
sacrifices in order for them all to get
on with each other and in order for them
to succeed together so we have very much
a a sense of team we talk about the team
at school and there's the form group and
then there's the year group and then
there's the whole school and um why do
we sing God Save the King I mean the
thing is I am no royalist I do not have
the king's photo on mugs you know I I
you got a trometry mry mug I do not have
Royal stuff at home I don't really care
about all that stuff but the reason why
we sing God Save the King is because I
know that he is a symbol of of the
country and therefore of our britishness
and of what we share together and what
what we have in common that is what's
important and um we find what we do
works now obviously schools that have
different layouts maybe have AIT more of
a free time at lunch they may do
different things you know but given what
we do with our family lunch and all of
that stuff um we just we would have to
turn into a different type of school and
then you need to think well is it
reasonable to ask a school to give up
its whole ethos to totally transform in
order for for for us to have prayer
rooms is that a reasonable thing and um
I don't think it is you know cther and
is this is this really is there an
element of this where it's just one
disgruntled student essentially who by
the way from what I've read was a bit of
a troublemaker is that is that where
this is coming from do you think or is
this really somebody making a stand on
principle it's hard to say you know it
is it's hard to say um I don't know I
mean at the end of the day I understand
um different religious groups wanting
different things um and not just
religious groups you know there are all
kinds of groups that want different
things but um you know our small CA
conservative values that I was saying
what are they We Believe very much in
personal responsibility the children
taking responsibility for their homework
and all the rest of it and if you know
not to blame other people not to see
yourself as a victim um so and that's
very much part of our culture we believe
in having a duty towards other people
towards your form so if a child comes
back at the end of the day to their
tutor and he's had a detention uh or
three or four of them have had detention
the their their formor will say look
you've let us all down the team has been
let down they haven't just let
themselves down as the individual
they've let everyone down you know
because we are part of a collective we
owe something to the people around us
and so in that there's the idea of
self-sacrifice you know you sacrifice
things that are important to you when
you recognize that it makes it better
for everyone around you now um that's
some of also we teach them gratitude so
on a daily basis we have the children
give appreciations at lunch I would like
giv appreciation to Mr Eastman to Mr
Smith to the guest on our table Mr May
for coming all the way from East Lon to
visit our school Michaela so two claps
on two one two one two thank you I mean
it's lovely anyone who on that day you
think I really owe that person something
today and I want to be able to say thank
you we do it in a public fashion uh we
teach some gratitude because it makes
you into a happier person um and because
you're a better person for being someone
who's grateful and however little you
have in life you always have more than
somebody else so be grateful for it you
know as opposed to seeing yourself as a
victim life is so hard for me so while I
say that yes I believe that racism
exists and so on if all you ever do is
see everything through that lens and see
yourself as this victim so you know yes
things happen to me that might you know
have a racist tone to them if I went
round life all the time thinking about
that well I never have set up my school
I would never have succeeded as I have
um and that's the thing that I often
find the left don't understand once I
went and gave a talk this is relatively
recently I talked about what we do in
exactly as I'm just doing with you and
um this white woman came up to me and
she said but what about the racism why
aren't you teaching them about the
racism and I said sorry you know I mean
the you know forget the irony of this
white woman telling me how terrible
racism is and um she said you must tell
them about the racism and I said well
you know they do know that they're black
and brown you
know I know and she said but but you've
got to tell them because how are they
going to cope in life otherwise and I
said okay so we teach them how to jump
over obstacles we teach them resilience
and stoicism we teach them how to handle
difficulties in life and how to make
something of their life there will be
all sorts of obstacles in their lives
some of those may be racist obstacles
some of those may be any kind of huge
numbers of obstacles the point is do
they have the resilience and the the the
the ability to be able to get up you get
knocked down you pick yourself up you
keep on going I said that this morning
in assembly I say it practically in
every assembly you know the fact is
that's what they need if I go on and on
about how the establishment is against
them and the man is against them and so
on well then they give up then they
think what's the point because I don't
belong in this country I'm not I'm not
welcome here and that is what I often
find the more the extreme left don't
understand is that if they're constantly
promoting that kind of division and by
the way just to say you know in terms of
diversity I am the poster girl for
diversity I mean what I mean by that my
own family background you know I've got
a Muslim grandmother I've got a Hindu
grandfather well I mean they're dead now
but you know I did um I've got a a black
Jamaican mother my father is of Indian
Heritage but grew up in in Guyana um you
know the I mean the fact is I'm a I'm
I'm a mix mhm right and and actually
even within our own family I saw this
you know you you over the years you know
how do you get the different groups to
mix and you know this idea that um that
only white people can be racist I
mean you know it's just nonsense my
father um being of Indian Heritage and
in Guyana there is a big divide between
the black people and the the brown
people the Indian descent people in in
Guyana and and when my father married my
mother his family you know they stopped
talking to him I mean that you know now
over the years that changed and so on
you know but it was it was a it was a
scandalous thing that he did you know um
and so the fact is race is is race and
religion are are are difficult things to
to talk about and to deal with um and
children are so influenced by what they
experience as children
so that is why our jobs around
socialization with children um helping
them to um uh see beyond the confines of
race religion uh sexuality and what is
so terrible is that these days that's
all that's being promoted and our
Humanity has been lost why do we read
Shakespeare because there is a Common
Thread of humanity in there and that
whether you're black or white or Hindu
or Muslim you understand what jealousy
is you understand what what war is you
understand what what anger is and all
that shakespare does what love is you
know um that is what we should be trying
to do meanwhile yeah you are doing you
are doing and and I'm grateful that you
are doing that uh we try to talk about
some of these things on our show in
order to do the same thing that you were
doing in a smaller way which is just to
put that idea out there that human
beings can connect human beings instead
of looking at each other through skin
color and all all sorts of other things
yes so I'm really grateful that Mikel
exists and I hope you are allowed to
continue with that ethos because I think
it's much needed uh when is the court
case and when can we expect an outcome
in your case well I mean this say it
could be a couple of months we don't
really know so we're just sort of
waiting I have to say I wait with
trepidation
because whatever the Press has been now
I expect it will be a hundred times more
when that verdict comes out um
but you know we got a soldier on um we
got to fight what what for what's right
you know our our our Western values um
you know people take them for granted
they they they think it's normal to have
societies that that mix successfully and
that you you get on a bus and it works
and you get on the tube and it works and
and that you know what city do you live
in
C she was about to say you get on the
train at work
no K we joke you're 100% right they take
it for granted think it's normal and I
feel like saying to them go and travel
you know the thing is it was one of the
things that helped me when I was a
teacher I was I was on the left very
much so um and I changed my mind to
become more of a small sea conservative
because I went and visited other
countries and I I worked a summer in
South Africa in schools I visited
schools in India and China and in
Jamaica and and all over you you know
and um I saw what what what it's like
elsewhere you know what is it like
elsewhere well
um groups don't necessarily mix
together she's putting it very gently
yeah um you know uh the the schools
don't have the resources and the the
teaching quality is nowhere near what
we've got and um things that we take for
granted that a bell rings between the
lessons you know it just simple stuff
like that just wouldn't happen you know
um and then of course the poverty that
you see elsewhere the uh the the
terrible ways in which uh people are
treated I I um went to visit this school
that had been set up by a charity by a
man an Indian Heritage man but he was
American uh for darot children in India
I mean they couldn't go to the well
because other people wouldn't be able
you know they would k kick them away
because that well was not for darlot
people you know like it it was racism on
a level that you know that we we we're
totally unfamiliar with we don't know
what it's like um and I mean I always
say that Britain is is such a brilliant
place to live in terms of race you know
in terms of Europe my goodness I mean
you want racism you go and find other
parts of Europe forget about India and
China I mean in China oh my goodness I
racism is off off the charts you know
but um just in Europe other places in
Europe the kind of racism that you'll
find uh in Britain we're so we're
wonderful we're a wonderful country I
think um you know I remember watching
this uh movie with Denzel Washington uh
called Book of Eli and it's this
postapocalyptic world in which you know
most of the things we now take for
granted don't exist it's kind of a Mad
Max there nothing works you have to scr
for and and there's a young girl who
asked him what it was like before the
apocalypse happened and he said oh
people used to just take everything for
granted and the stuff that that we now
kill each other for they used to throw
in the bin yes and that's kind of how I
think about Britain and you know Western
countries mostly and the rest of the
world yes people in in the west just so
fundamentally don't appreciate what we
have here that's right and they've got
to go and see it with their own eyes
otherwise they never will that's right
well you know it's funny you mentioned
Denzel Washington because I I did my
assembly this morning partly on him and
um you know he gives this great speech
about how you got to keep working you
fall down uh seven times you get up
eight he says and um he says um that
ease is a greater threat to success than
hardship and I was saying to the kids
you got to push through the pain you
know you you got to push yourselves till
you feel it's hard right because if it
isn't hard if it's easy then you're not
really making a success of anything it's
it's got to be difficult you know and
Denzel Washington has done more than 64
films and he's 69 years old and he's
worth more than 280 million dollar um I
know this because I did my assembly this
morning on it and um and I was saying
look at this man he's so successful he
gives his little speech and at the end
he says see you at work because he works
all the time that's how he's made over
64 films you know and it it whatever
comes at him doesn't matter and he
understands that point you don't want it
to be easy you want it to be hard and
that's why our motto is work card be
kind and we took that motto your viewers
might be interested we took that motto
we stole it from Kip in the United
States uh the charter chain there they
used to have a motto called work hard be
nice and um we changed it to be kind
just to be different and when George
Floyd happened uh work hard be nice they
were accused of racism because if white
teachers are teaching black children to
be nice that means you're teaching black
children to be subservient
therefore it's racist and soip had to
abandon their motto now we still have
our mot we're be kind I'm not changing
it you know like what is this insanity
why can't a white teacher teach a black
child to be nice lend him a pen open the
door you know be kind to your friends I
don't understand it we've all lost our
minds I mean we've lost our minds and
there's something very important worth
saying here because within education
there are some people within it who see
as a controversial figure but there are
a lot of teachers believe me who I've
spoken to who've reached out to me who's
people that I I have also worked under
who see you as a Guiding Light and
someone pushing back against this
nonsense not because you're interested
in becoming a public figure but because
you care about the kids and that's what
it always comes down with with you
Catherine which is why it's it's always
a pleasure to have you on the show it's
always a pleasure to talk to about
education thank you so much for coming
on and the final question as always is
what's the one thing that we're not
talking about that we really should be
skulls beautiful and of course it's not
the final question because we have
questions from our supporters on locals
where we're going to head over in a
second and ask them and they all go
behind a pay wall on locals so they can
see that thanks for watching head on
over to locals for the rest of this
conversation
the best thing you can do for your
children and I say this to absolutely
[Music]
everyone